hey check me out on a bootleg cab show
it was lit full of energy
go
nah man check this out man bootleg Kim
yeah he heard it first
bootleg cat podcast
special guest one of my favorites yeah
been waiting on his album for a very
long time yeah about three and a half
years
2019-ish about that I bet that hey RJ's
here Mr La for sure welcome man how you
doing my brother how you feeling now
that you got this body of work finally
into the world I know you've been
working on it for a long time you [ __ ]
with it I do I think you know what's
crazy I feel like that you are the most
consistent
outside of Kendrick because we gotta
Give It Up to cada but I feel like
consistency
when I know you drop I just know that
there's a certain level of quality that
comes with RJ do you think he [ __ ]
with me
I think Kendrick's [ __ ] with
everybody so that's you know just to be
I mean do you want me to lie to you no I
I'm honesty I just think like when I
think about the city I'm like yo art I
just know I'm getting quality music from
RJ every [ __ ] go
timeless music and I think you're the
best performer uh I think your top five
performer in hip-hop to be honest
hip-hop yeah when I see you professional
bro I saw you at the real Street Fest
which was like 2019 as well when we had
our real 92.3 Festival you performed at
and I was just like in awe bro yeah
could you be [ __ ] you'd be popping
and locking it you got every movement
that it reminded me of like early Tech
N9 like when I used to see Tech Nine
when I was a kid shout out to Tech Nine
is another one of the greats
Tech would have like a movement for
every [ __ ] like bar and I feel like
you're kind of similar
you are you high right now no it's
really the beats that uh that tell the
story yeah the other song other
movements you know and the Beast we saw
you know like
like you know it'd be like yeah you know
what I'm saying my Beats really hit how
especially on stage I was gonna say how
like if you say inspired your like
performance game or did you just figure
that [ __ ] out on your own I'm a student
of the game yeah
when I was coming up we used to watch a
lot a lot of artists before and one
artist in particular
let's just Busta Rhymes of course
he uh made an announcement you know I
said artist you need to start performing
yep and
I Tookie
and I started studying performers
and I I just developed my own style
get smart and bus is one of those ones
man for sure him and spliff star you
seen him live in person for sure it's a
[ __ ] fire so yeah you are yeah buses
will go for sure they just they just did
a
where were they in L.A was a Hollywood
Bowl well Nas it was Nas Buster Wu-Tang
Clan yeah shout out to bus
um shout out Kendrick though because you
spoke on him he's a great performer too
amazing
yeah did you go to the uh the this the
tour I mean he had like seven dates in
L.A it was good
it was dope Kendrick is also one of
those guys that can Captivate a crowd
without
you know I think some people mistake
screaming and jumping into a mosh pit
and crowd surfing and like just doing
wild [ __ ] on stage with like good
performing and like sure sometimes that
goes over well
but I think like your breath control how
you sound like how captivating you are
without doing all the crazy Antics on
stage to me is like very
more is more important right because
like anybody can like throw [ __ ] and
crowd Surf and yeah I'll be looking at
that like that's that's cool yeah it's
like cool it's like cool if you can't
perform when you're like rapping over
your [ __ ] track all right it's cool
it like wrapping over two tracks yeah
you're rapping over your two track but
you [ __ ] jumped off of a speaker and
you know sprained your ankle so
everyone's like yo you're a God bro
you know what I'm saying yeah uh yo the
album is dope though man thank you bro
thank you I really I love the tie record
the OT record is just super flagrantly
[ __ ] disrespectful which I love
what's up it was like a classic you got
a just a classic OT moment yeah shout
out my brother man okay what did he
rhyme vagina with on the song China and
vagina
listen any song in which they rhyme
China with vagina it's amazing yeah
because Hilo has a song Too Short he was
talking about how to make a girl make
money off of her pee hole and I was like
I love that China vagina love it yeah
you guys it sucks to be it's crazy
because like I feel like um
somehow
throughout the pandemic I know the club
scene is popping in La again but I feel
like we kind of lost like I kind of
missed Playhouse
does that make sense we gotta understand
a lot of the money left with the
pandemic I just feel like so it's not a
lot of I still like poppy they're still
like you know there's still spots like
the LA function is dope like obviously
uh Penthouse uh but I just like I miss
Playhouse
I feel like Playhouse was like the spot
where like you could go and like you
could really have a temperature on what
La sounds like at the time well like you
know
one of people who's in charge of
playoffs is that dragonfly now so you
know I haven't been through different
place still got [ __ ] going on it's just
relocated yeah and so I'm the type of
pro name since the pandemic I've just
decided I'm not going outside unless I'm
getting paid or unless it's some [ __ ]
where I'm like it's the homie I gotta go
support I'd be [ __ ] tired bro that
makes sense I'm with the kids [ __ ] for
sure you understand what's up
um how many songs like did you pull from
for this project like I know you've been
recording three years now you know so
was there like how many songs didn't
make the album
um
uh Steven was there I got a lot of songs
a lot yeah it was it was there okay uh
four songs from the entire like three
years is what I
you know that stayed on album
and then the rest we was in the record
plan for 10 days I think we recorded
like probably like 75 percent of the
project yeah like 30 songs or something
like that oh [ __ ]
so there's four records on here that are
older in terms of just the timeline of
when you started recording in the since
the last album yeah everything else you
knocked out in that 10-day period
correct wow
do you feel like you ever become a um a
victim of demoitis where we'll show yeah
because like artists will have songs
where everybody will hear them and
they're like yo that's a [ __ ] hit but
you listen to your own [ __ ] and your
Crews listening to your own [ __ ] so much
that you it gets played out to you well
not oh good songs are good songs but um
more so in the songs are being mastered
we get demolitis
and we just be like nah it needs to
sound like the demo
true or if like you something like the
the engineer like the engineer would be
like you know cleaning it up making it
clean but we like the rough we like the
raw yeah material like it happens a lot
you know we like how it sound rough but
we just cleaned it up even if I give
away too much sauce no that's a lot of
sauce that's really a lot of sauce right
there I mean I have an artist and we're
just going through his album and there
was a sauce some [ __ ] got moved around
like and I was like yeah nah that's
that's not how I know it to be yeah you
know what I mean especially I think that
should be happening too when like
there's like a demo hook cut on
someone's record and you have the demo
version for so long for so long
then the big artist gets on and you're
like man I don't know yeah well the big
artist they got on these records
well it's high the funny [ __ ] we had a
record that we did we had two records
that we did with Todd in the same day
and we just picked we picked the one
that we went with that starts with
delivery that [ __ ] was like that [ __ ]
was done both of them is fire so what
happens to the other one uh man it was
just this goes involved you guys are
like uh well I'm saying I'd be like yo I
want both yeah if he wanted he could
have it though I'm not stingy put it on
the deluxe when it comes to tie are you
gonna do a delay
um I don't know yeah that's kind of like
mundane to me yeah everybody doing the
deluxes and [ __ ] like that I'd rather
just do a whole another project I love
that like I don't know just don't make
us wait three years nah I'm back in the
in the bag now I'm back in that motion
so I pretty much want to put out a lot
of content and I don't want to
oversaturate it but I want to put out a
lot of great content because you know
tomorrow's not promise so facts about
there how many music videos do you have
in the can right now
um we pretty much go with the flow
videos you kind of just let the fans
tell you which which joints to shoot I
respect that that's smart
um
obviously you've had a great
relationship with Thug over time uh
shout out to Young Thug free man free
slime man free free dope free slime free
Gunner
Freedom guys man free YSL for real for
real he was on the last album right yeah
yeah you guys shot the video and
everything uh he's somebody who I feel
like
super tapped in with your movement
[Music]
um
I always hear just about how great of a
guy he is like he's very generous
um how did you guys initially link up oh
we
I'll perform and he was like who's that
yeah he already knew who I was he told
me he told me he already knew who I was
also you opened up on tour for him
correct it was you him and MGK correct
that was before I met him I was after I
met him though right right for people
who don't know your guys's full history
yeah I met him at uh legiardi he was out
of Jordan uh they told me to pull up I
pulled up I performed
but you know what I'm saying I blew
everybody away per usual and
we uh you know shook hands
turned up after that and then it was
cool after that then
I met him again I got reacquainted with
Joe Moses I was you know sliding around
with your Moses Joe muzzle with future
yeah Etc you know that's the team by
everything and all them that's yeah yeah
I mean with the slides boom and yeah
as soon as I went to the studio he just
like you trying to record
and then that's history wow and we just
went from there and then put me on the
tour
went crazy was there a conversation to
have you maybe come over to YSL
um nah he just always tried to push my
career forward and that's devised me to
do you know make proper steps and proper
moves and [ __ ]
things that work for him things that
don't work you know and just you know
bless [ __ ] with gang and I respect
that a lot of art almost will only do
that if they have the motive of trying
to get you onto their label at the end
of the day you know what I'm saying is
the fact he does he did that like from a
selfless point of view
and I'll pick up on that too like I tell
the people I'm with y'all got a sign of
me yeah I would love you too sign with
me if you're great if you're a great
talent but you don't have to sign with
me it's just really about being under
the umbrella and you know [ __ ] with
the squad and knowing that we family and
we got your
you know what I'm saying got your back
fully hey what up y'all bootleg cab got
to stop the interview to tell you about
our newest sponsor man shout out to the
homies at hardean Las Vegas that's right
the number one dispensary in the whole
state of Nevada let alone in the whole
[ __ ] country so many choices of
Premium cannabis ladies and gentlemen it
is like how can I put this you walk into
it you go to hardine in Las Vegas
when you're on vacation when you're out
there tricking off whatever you're doing
stop off at hardean tell them I sense
you'll be like yo bootleg have sent me
they're gonna take care of you at
hardean when I say selection I mean
selection of the best premium cannabis
in the world the best dispensary there's
a reason why hardeen is world famous
follow them right now Harding underscore
Las Vegas go to their website
hardinglasvegas.com that's
j-a-r-d-i-n underscore Las Vegas when
you're in Vegas you have to pull up to
hardine tell them I sent you and get
high off your [ __ ] face I don't even
know what that means how do you get high
off of your face whatever melt your
[ __ ] face off with some of that good
hard Dean y'all go follow one more time
that's Hardy in underscore Las Vegas
let's get back to the interview how was
it um touring with MGK who's another
amazing performer he thought too he's
dope that had to be that's a [ __ ]
crazy tour if we just think about the
historical context of RJ and GK Young
Thug tour so what was that 2019 what's
up yeah yeah
that was real dope it was fun and you
know we got into a lot yeah you know
just he's a wild boy I mean I know he
has a song called another we ain't
getting into nothing too bad [ __ ] like
that like it's just typical tour [ __ ]
right getting [ __ ] up going to
different cities going to different
states yeah you know being on the road
and you know and you know [ __ ] missing
home things like that just regular you
know just turning up and [ __ ] just
giving our
a little energy you know what I'm saying
given 132 percent in every city in every
state so that's pretty much what it'd be
like
um talk to me about who is on the label
um
see that day off top he's been here
before so uh Bree Carter brick Carter
stop shot eight is pretty Cartier
let's see your lady or my mother of my
children your baby mama okay yeah okay
mother of my children you're you're a
mother of your children yes yes all
right okay oh
she's on she's on there
um she was on the Jeezy record too right
correct
uh Mike Wayne
okay poppy uh splack
um got another artist named Melody
Melody baby
uh he's Egyptian and he's just tight
he's got a dope ass voice
um
we got producers that's just under the
umbrella right you know
um
Larry Jay hmm
wow
my boy man we got him 89 [ __ ] with us
um
my boy Freddie Ruger
and we just you know
we're just flooding is there anything
you learned because you would obviously
been under the 10 something I want to
shout out G4 too G4 yeah young cat too
try G4 yeah you [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] you
know that's just family I'm just
speaking on people that's just a lot of
times I speak on just family and knowing
that I you know I want to you know share
my platform why not you feel me what you
should do yeah yeah I'm not that type of
person where you just like if you ain't
signing me I'm not [ __ ] with you no
more right type [ __ ] I was gonna say
what did you learn from
um the 10 summer situation that you're
applying to amio because mustard
obviously
is a [ __ ] boss you know what I'm
saying um you guys put out some timeless
music together for so was there anything
you learned from that uh experience that
you're applying to your own imprint now
yeah for sure
I learned a lot from myself I learned
you know
first hand on how to deal with you know
situations at hand you feel me even
being involved with you know I'm saying
who you're involved with it's just like
you know always you know I mean do you
you know I mean keep your your best foot
forward you know I'm saying I wouldn't
be in the game if it wasn't for myself
he took a
he single-handedly took me under his
wing and you know shot shot a lot of
light on you know what I'm saying I
learned like the business too you feel
me being on your being on your ball
standing on business
you know what I'm saying [ __ ] like that
it's real dope oh a lot to him uh
every chance I get you know I speak that
you know but you know what I'm saying
that's why you know being independent is
it's like it's kind of like easy for me
not easy because it's a lot of weight on
our shoulders and [ __ ] like that but you
know being independent you know we try
to like
you know tackle certain certain
mainstream tactics you know what I'm
saying right take certain mainstream
tactics and you know go with the flow
and [ __ ] like that you know because you
know being independent like you gotta
do do more of the the the work on the
business side more work yeah you know
what I'm saying for sure it's a lot more
work it's a lot more tedious but it's a
lot more rewarding the payoff is worth
it yeah for sure because this is your
second album since I guess leaving the
inner scope [ __ ] right
yes yeah actually
um
my first album was my first album period
on God was my first album period
I would when I was signed I was only
signed for uh two mixtapes which was two
those two projects right which was Mr LA
and the ghetto right everything else was
amio those were independent early those
were yeah those are independent release
records yeah you feel me so opposed Army
your records is what you know we have
titles that's amazing
um which keeps us afloat and keeps us
going I mean you got some [ __ ]
Classics man yeah some real classic not
more a little bit above a float but yes
that's fair uh you know what I
appreciate about you is like one of the
early things that had happened in La
when I first moved out here was you and
Greedo did the first verses correct
definitely the first verses
it was at the novo
correct and the observatory
you guys did do two the first one was at
the novo though right um the first one
was Adam services oh she see um the
first one was they thought everybody was
gonna die
yeah I mean I remember talking ahead and
he's like I'm not gonna be there and I
was like we should go and I'm like you
know what I'm gonna listen anything La
related I just listened to head on I'm
like you know what you're right head
yeah uh and it was a success you know it
was so dope because I remember y'all
going back and forth online and then you
guys had this [ __ ] incredible event
where everybody was on stage right and
it just felt like wow this is like this
is like history low-key for sure it was
basically like you know it was what
Gucci and Jeezy did
but we did it because our show was more
like in the mo in the in the in the
moment it was in the moment that's what
made it different yeah for sure and the
fact that there was no incidents is
amazing yeah for sure when did you guys
talk like before it went down like was
there like a little meet up backstage
that Ayla we'll keep respectful we'll
make sure no we didn't know what was
gonna happen what the [ __ ] well I was
gonna whip his ass it was just organized
chaos but then we just like you know
kept it cool and I'll just plan we we
talked about it yeah no we talked about
it um on the phone because it got out of
hand it got out of hand on the
um like on the internet right internet
you know always blows things over
proportion and you know when you don't
have communication you know it [ __ ] up
the nation so you know we talked about
are we uh uh shout out
um oh noses also an artist my excuse my
fault I said my father enough that he's
also the artist from amio
um but you know he's always been around
you don't know so yeah uh but him and
Mafia horn they got involved and you
know they Mafia horn talked to Greedo
knows to talk to me and we got on the
phone and when we got on the phone it
was like you know it was it was like
that you know what I'm saying initially
yeah but you know they talked to us
talk some sense into us and then we you
know I'm saying we carried out the show
and it kept it going because it's really
bigger than us yeah sometimes you know
being in the moments you don't
understand that sometimes being in the
beef you don't understand that
um it's bigger than you
you got the Focus right now people own
you right now they perpetuating this
beef they perpetuating it and making it
blow up but it's bigger than you you
know it's more about y'all a hole you
feel me what both of y'all represent and
it could be detrimental so like
sometimes you gotta rise above yourself
and rise above the situation and really
like see yourself above it and see the
whole game and look at yourself from a
bird's eye view and you know being moved
up move accordingly you know what I'm
saying so that's what we did we just
seen ourselves first off you and moved
accordingly and we made money off that
[ __ ] that was like my first fifty
thousand dollar show wow okay give me 50
bands off the show
I did [ __ ] shout out to you what's a
good [ __ ] day for sure that's a great
day
what's up was that the Nova and we got
two of them Jesus
salute for sure hey we gotta stop the
interview real quick to tell you about
our partners at Odd Socks our presenting
sponsor here at the bootleg hit podcast
listen Christmas time is approaching
faster than you think I mean we're like
[ __ ] a month and a half away or some
[ __ ] whatever uh get some Odd Socks for
your folks go to oddsoxofficial.com use
the promo code bootleg and you'll save
20 off at checkout the most comfortable
socks in the world that's right
we got some Scarface socks they got WWE
yeah I mean they also got the Cheech and
chongs they also got the Flamin Hots for
you hot Cheeto eating [ __ ] out there my
favorite just the odd Sox Basics they're
just so comfy
literally the most comfortable sock in
the world I'm holding the [ __ ] sock
right now you can save 20 off plus they
got boxers now baby all right go to Odd
Socks official.com promo code bootleg at
checkout save 20 off and support our
family at odd Sox and the podcast at the
same [ __ ] time let's get back to the
interview you mentioned stepping out
it's so hard for people to remove
themselves from their own situation and
try to look at it from like an outside
point of view yeah something I got on my
side though too and I got good people
around me that want to see me win yeah
because they know if I win they win
yes I feel like it's it's uh you know as
part of growing up too man it's like you
because you're always gonna have like a
biased opinion on what's going on
because you're in it but if you could
just look at it from like how it looks
like from the outside like you you you
know a lot of people make short-sighted
decisions because they don't do that
correct do you feel like um
nowadays you're kind of like a big homie
in L.A you know what I mean so
um do you find yourself like giving game
to artists that you see that you admire
that you might maybe see [ __ ] up or
moving like a way in which you might
just be able to be like hey let me give
you some game real quick type [ __ ] I'll
talk most definitely uh give game a lot
it's just oh
you know up apply
but is you going to use it though yeah
like I might tell you about it but are
you gonna like listen yeah like I'm not
really into wasting my breath because
for your energy all my energy no so
I
I sort of picked certain times when to
speak it otherwise you're just trying to
hear yourself speak like an old head
you're trying to hear yourself talk
right that's the time being Wise It's
not saying nothing at all feel me yeah
so sometimes you just gotta pick the
winning right time to say it in the
right time to speak I just you know so
like you know I'll pop it a little bit
you know get my game but you know you
gotta
know how to give it though I'm saying
and win and win exactly
you know now and being a big homie and
being like you know evening some [ __ ]
like my little brothers I get mad too
and I lose sometimes I could lose my
cool and jump out of character too I'm
I'm happy you know I'm human too so
you know I [ __ ] up players [ __ ] up but
at the end of the day like it's about
you know recovering and just like hey
you know what being man enough and be
like hey look man I [ __ ] up it you
know this is how I should have came you
know what I'm saying so being a big
homie like
I had to you know I got to take on those
certain roles when I was younger I was
just like I don't give a [ __ ] right here
right right you feel me like I don't
care like they got my bad but now that
I'm older I realize that people
um and not just older just wiser I
realize that people have to like like
people have to understand you
you can't just be out here popping [ __ ]
and you just look like a you know an old
head right it's not cool like I know how
we used to like yeah when people gotta
respect you if you're if like you said
if you don't always speak when you do
speak it carries more weight true you
know what I mean and they also have to
like respect you to listen for sure you
know what I mean like you just can't
pull put your arm around some young kid
that you just saw on Instagram hey man
you [ __ ] up bro [ __ ] out of here bro
yeah yeah that's real
um yo what is like for you because
obviously La is you know you have like I
said man you got Classics bro
when you look at the metrics what is
your biggest Market outside of the State
of California
I don't know I think I need to pay more
attention to that you're gonna put that
back in on Spotify man yeah what about
like
last time you're on tour did you notice
like a random City where you're like oh
[ __ ] they were really [ __ ] with me in
so and so or wherever it's hard to tell
because my energy is everyone's [ __ ]
with you yeah like once I'm done it's
like everybody [ __ ] it's my energy is
Electrify yeah so they [ __ ] with me it's
like hard to tell like if they knew the
words already right right right and my
songs are you know I know how to tell
hooks yeah I know how to tell a story I
know how to speak to the audience you
know so I can get them to say what's
going on because you know what I'm
saying my message is pure so like it's
kind of hard as far as when I'm
performing and touring but
um I I honestly I do need to pay more
attention to who's
you know trying to you know I deal with
the same pains that my homies deal with
I'm not gone I'm not too far I'm not
far-fetched I'm you know I'm here they
can touch me and [ __ ] so it's kind of
like I deal with the same deaths the
same Joy the same accomplishments you
know I mean like when my homies is up
and they winning I see that and I feel
that you feel me so I'm just right here
so I feel like
um sometimes you could be trapped
do you feel like you sometimes you can
get lost in the sauce of LA and not
think of like the the country
because I feel like sometimes I could
never be lost in sauce man well you know
I don't mean listen I'm not talking
about from a Gucci Mane perspective okay
no you can't you could let me lost in
the summer
[Laughter]
something about America have they could
he could have sauce but he could be you
know I'm saying if you don't got sauce
you lost in the sauce you feel me like
no do you ever have like do you ever
feel like um you know what's going on
you like I'm just playing
you stuck out you could focus too much
on La and and and at times let the
bigger picture Fall by the wayside
because I do feel like sometimes an LA
artist we see like a ceiling get hit and
it's like yo we know you're lit from
here to Seattle Arizona Vegas right
sometimes Texas but like I think
sometimes like La artists are so like
focused on La that it's not I'm not even
talking about sonically I just mean like
you said earlier like damn I need to pay
attention more like you know uh
something that Kailyn did early on that
I loved was like he just went out to
Atlanta for like six months you know
yeah he was out there like he was out
there you know what I mean he tapped in
with a lot like and I I saw that from
the jump and I was like oh that's that's
something I see a lot of people doing
that um blue box do that yeah
um
[Music]
um
another person who did it Mozzy did that
[ __ ] big time you know what I'm saying
he did that but I don't know bro oh you
know [ __ ] I'm having fun that's all that
matters feeding your family feeding my
family I'm having fun I'm enjoying life
um I I cross those but you know what I'm
saying I once when I get through those
Crossroads then for sure I do need to
pay attention to it though for sure you
know and when I get there I'll get there
but right now I got right here to deal
with you know it's people that I have to
deal with I have to you know make sure
they're straight I have to make sure
people are saying right times you know
what I'm saying sometimes when I'm gone
too long you know [ __ ]
[ __ ] up you know what I'm saying they
ruptures and [ __ ] like that like so I
hold a lot of [ __ ] together and and I
stand on that and I could I could you
know what I'm saying if if you know if
yet they blow up and he gets you know
I'm saying to you know uh New York and
all that [ __ ] for sure that's I'm you
know we we there you know I feel like
two hit like sonically he's like an
artist that I could see that really
happening with all right
I feel like he has that young soul that
uh
the world needs
hmm I feel like he has that that
hunger that the world needs to you know
I'm saying experience for sure
um
what if you had to pick a song that you
could never perform again what would be
the song You're just kind of tired of
performing
tired of Performing are you are you or
is it is it none yeah I don't know
because when I came in the game I came
um
you know
making songs or like which song of yours
is the most played out to you
played out yeah like a song where you're
like yo if I never heard this song from
me again it's it's fine because I've
heard it a million times like is it get
rich is it like or is it you just like
no these are my like you know some
artists are like what you're trying to
say I'm saying you got some [ __ ] huge
records and do they get played out to
you no no okay I gotta ask oh yeah no no
no it's a comment sometimes you know
it's a compliment I'm trying to
compliment I appreciate you my brother I
can talk to you yeah what the [ __ ] you
trying to say bruh I can talk to you you
know what I'm saying I could be up front
I can be real with you you know because
sometimes you know questions be hidden
[ __ ] in questions you'll hear like I'm
like I I you'll hear artists be like yo
I'm so [ __ ] sick like I'm sure Roddy
rich is tired of the Box you know what I
mean he has to be there's no way Roddy's
not tired of the box at least personally
for me I'm tired of the box I don't know
and I don't have to perform it I don't
know because like people ask me
questions like this all the time right
and they'd be um it'd be like new people
with me like it'd probably be a new
security new bodyguard with me or
something like that right or just new
people people and they'll just be at all
what's going on you know because
you know it'd be fans running up and RJ
let me get a picture random times and
[ __ ] like that and they asked me
um do I ever get tired of that and it's
like they cannot be running up to me
right
you know like I could not be performing
these songs true you know so
um no I love these songs these songs
just feed my family these songs just
making sure my kids grow strong right
you know I mean I love these songs when
I came in the game I came to make songs
that we can live on for 10 years
you know and Beyond you know like that's
why my songs are so you know deep rooted
into your soul into your bones because I
I do that intentionally right like I
said I'm
when I'm in La like I hold [ __ ] together
it's like that [ __ ] is real it's not
just about me right you know it's it's a
whole like Mr La is somebody for real
it's not
just a man a name that somebody made up
oh wait what up y'all we gonna stop the
interview real quick tell you about our
good friends at my bookie that's right
man my bookie is where you want to get
this money and uh enjoy uh being a
degenerate like myself and it's the best
time of the year to be a degenerate
because NFL season is uh obviously we
are in the midst of a crazy NFL season
NBA season just started World Series is
going down and you can get your bets in
right now go to my bookie and sign up
for a new account using the promo code
bootleg that's
b-o-o-t-l-e-g you sign up right now they
will match your first deposit that's
right put in a thousand oh they'll give
you another thousand to gamble with
that's free money free money to gamble
with let's get in on this action man NFL
season I'm loving this part of the year
so much good just everything to bet on
football basketball [ __ ] UFC uh NFL
baseball whatever now is the best time
to get your gamble on so go sign up for
a new account at mybookie use that promo
code bootleg and double your deposit
let's get back to the interview outside
of La outside of Cali if you could do a
joint mixtape album with another other
rapper who to be
right now yeah right now
outside L.A can't be California the
state of California is off limits and
anyone who signed your label is off
limits
younger oh it could be anybody y'all
give me a young animal both all right go
first who what young or old young young
um Boston Boston Bridge peacefire yeah
so Boston Richie on the young side what
about on the old side a fire
outside uh
dead or alive
let's be honest yeah I mean yeah you
could say [ __ ] two pockets he was
from New York and Baltimore but you know
that would be cheating okay oh
not from L.A guys just so you didn't
know yeah yeah right like you know
because there's a lot of artists from La
I would love to do mixtapes with you
know nope I'm just saying I would love
to hear you on blast do a project that
would be kind of hard you and Seattle
would be dope um
I don't know I don't know about you and
Busta Rhymes would be dope you think so
yeah why not you guys could [ __ ] go
on a tour and you guys can [ __ ] try
to outperform each other be a lot of
calories burned on stage I think I got
them right now though he dope though
cause I just seen him right not to be
turned up but about another negative
though but I'm just saying uh
I seen him do some [ __ ] on stage bro
that was dope as [ __ ] it didn't take a
lot of energy it just was real
like it just had it was just real like
Poise yeah you know what I mean like he
he he act like he he act like he [ __ ]
up
no no what he do he uh
he went he uh the music was turned up
and then he turned it down like but he
rapping though and he going low he going
low he going low he going low and then
he turned the [ __ ] back up and I'm
looking at this [ __ ] like this [ __ ]
genius it's amazing it's [ __ ] genius
so I'm just like damn it's certain
things like that I like to take when I
like the steel though but yeah steal it
I got blood a lot of people do that it's
not like Busta Rhymes is the only guy
doing that
let's see who else you know I'm doing
that I've seen that before I can't tell
you off the top of my head it was
something else he did that I just wanted
to you know mainly expose his little his
show but yeah I mean he's on tour right
now with Wu-Tang and if you can go see
it for your [ __ ] self I mean go see
uh Busta Rhymes on tour right now go see
Busta Rhymes the tour might be over
actually Wu-Tang I like that show yeah
if you can get all night well you can't
get all nine guys because you know
r.i.p.odb but if you could get Method
Man to show up to a Wu show it's amazing
meth is very like
he's kind of like one foot in one foot
out on the woo [ __ ] I think he only did
like four of the dates on the tour but
it has a dope performance of amazing and
he's yoked I seen this big ass [ __ ]
stage dog bro all that [ __ ] was crazy
Method Man Method Man stays these days
though bro and [ __ ] nobody caught him
oh man bro this [ __ ] is a fool he got
up like it was nothing shook it off and
[ __ ] I'm like it's [ __ ] big as [ __ ] bro
that [ __ ] I think a [ __ ] got
kicked in the face excuse me I don't
mean to say [ __ ] and [ __ ] yeah you
know but yeah it's a term of endearment
nah because I got a lot of female I got
a lot of female fans it sounds good on
the record it sounds great it sounds
great on the record but you know coming
without a beat it don't sound like you
know what I'm saying that's fair I got a
lot of females I respect you know what
I'm saying we only disrespect women on
Beats
so look
look this but I say that [ __ ] one time I
started stage I I did that [ __ ] one time
you've jumped off stage did you get
caught no I didn't get caught I think I
kicked somebody in the head nobody even
knew me though at that time
you've not been booed before bro when
like I think I was like opening up for
like tiger or somebody like Jesus At The
Observatory what year was this that show
was like 2015 14 no 2014 23. so this was
like 2013 or something like that rack
city had already been out all that yeah
he already going up Last Kings people
are wearing that and I opened up right
before him
so I'm gonna open up right before him
right and
like
they Restless they ready to see the man
I see tiger they pay to see tiger
terrible clothes on
Pharaoh t-shirt on I'm doing my [ __ ] and
like in the middle of my performance
they just like Boo
[ __ ] off the sticks
[ __ ] I'm like
so I'm like what oh I bet so I play a
song that everybody I know they know
this [ __ ] so I'm like Oh my Play [ __ ]
[Music]
whole crowd went crazy right they like
oh that's you cause nobody knew right my
song they didn't know who else was I
played that [ __ ] they went crazy I'm
like yeah [ __ ] ass [ __ ] yeah like I'm
going the [ __ ] up like yeah [ __ ] that's
right yeah yo yeah you thought I was a
nobody yeah yeah but y'all know my
record no [ __ ] I bought that one but
they going crazy like oh my God that's
you I love this record I'm like yeah for
sure but things like that I take you
know what I'm saying and I remember [ __ ]
like that and I'll be like damn look
where I'm at today
that wasn't the show you tried to crowd
surfing was it it might have been bad
business decision because they were just
booing you they sure the [ __ ] are gonna
catch you I've been at this I think they
pulled me after that
I definitely I've crowd surfed a bunch
and I got dropped like who is this [ __ ]
yeah nah but I just got a [ __ ] though
bro love I love my trials and
tribulations I love what I what I what I
came from I could never forget it you
know what I'm saying and I got so much
room so much more room to go it's dope
because it's a whole world that don't
know who Laura J is any uh touring or
live shows coming up for this album
oh yeah I got the um I got the novo
um you know his backyard yeah Lenovo
November 4th
um you know make sure y'all grab your
tickets man uh it's gonna be dope we got
a lot of [ __ ] going on tons of special
guests coming up the show you know what
I'm saying I am the one that brought out
Snoop Dogg yes that is me even I am him
you know what I'm saying
shout out Snoop man you got a joint
Snoop is the guy he's a joint like for
real I don't I don't know what that
means
I mean I know like if I see a girl
that's pretty I'm like yo that's a joint
right there or if I'm smoking a joint
whatever interpolation you're using
right now I haven't heard yet so please
explain oh for real hey man [ __ ] what
you want for me you want me to lie to
you I don't want no lies man I want
honesty pure honesty man that's what I
want I need honesty like if I see Rosa
Acosta I'll be like yeah that's a joint
right there yeah shout out to her you
know Snoop Dogg smoking joints yeah but
also a joint simultaneously
yeah there's that like a joint like a
top boy top boy he's a top boy for sure
pause for sure oh man for sure for sure
greatest of all time uh
possibly
so
best best rap album
second best rap album ever is doggy
style in my opinion so what Illmatic I'm
a Nas guy so yeah I feel you it wasn't
soft it won't be honest it wasn't
Illmatic wasn't like doggy style has
aged way better than no matter that's
why I was trying to that's where I was
going with it that's where I was going
with it like if you play doggy style
right now it's just like a it's I just
you can feel doggy style today
doggy style is uh today tomorrow a year
from now 10 years you're gonna feel
doggy style for sure
that's what I [ __ ] with that's what I
come from that's where I stem from I
think Snoop Dogg I was on you know I was
on on tourism too which was this one of
the uh with him and like I want to thank
me to it oh okay okay yeah you didn't
know that bro I don't [ __ ] know
Snoopy on tour so [ __ ] much it's like
him it's E40 it's too short it's Ice
Cube it's every Amphitheater from here
to [ __ ] Wichita I don't [ __ ] know
snoop's never not on tour bro I can't
keep track who the [ __ ] on toward the
Snoop oh well there's a lot of Snoop
tours happening you know now that
[ __ ] stays get in the bag for
sure stays getting the bag that's what
it's about uh you know
let me preach that
let me let me laugh yeah that [ __ ]
preach that [ __ ] it's about keeping the
bag like you know I'm saying setting up
bags we got bags set up for next year
you got to man
that's how you know you got a good guy
in your corner for sure yep hey guys we
gotta stop the interview to tell you
about our good folks over at
bluechoo.com that's right listen you
gotta go to Bluetooth
for uh Bluetooth with the promo code
bootleg you're gonna get your first
month for free Bluetooth the same active
ingredient adds Viagra Ana Cialis but in
a chewable form that's right you pop the
blue shoe chew that thing wash it down
with your beverage of choice and then
get to work with that hard [ __ ] [ __ ]
of yours your dick is going to be harder
than trigonometry was in high school
ladies and gentlemen it's gonna be
[ __ ] raw like you know uh Ryu and
Street Fighter he'd be like and he does
the [ __ ] this is gonna be your
dick it's gonna be like ryu's [ __ ]
uppercut you know what I'm saying God
bless whoever's on the receiving end of
that consensually of course uh they're
gonna thank you for taking the blue shoe
so go to bluetooth.com use the promo
code bootleg all right I'm talking free
month right to your doorstep in discreet
packaging no awkward doctors visits all
right it's all online you don't have to
worry about going and sitting in a
waiting room and be like my dick I could
use a little pep in my step and then
it's awkward you gotta look at this old
[ __ ] talking about your dick he might
ask you to pull it out who [ __ ] knows
what's going on at Bluetooth none of
that's happening boochu.com and they
also got the new brand new uh mint
flavored chewable which has
vardinophil in it which is the same
active ingredient as Levitra and
stackson which is a little more potent a
little more potent if you need the extra
on top of the extra you know what I mean
get the mint chewable yeah your wife
will thank you your girlfriend no thank
you your boyfriend will thank you
whatever the [ __ ] you're [ __ ] I'll
thank you as long as it's legal all
right let's get back to the interview go
to bluetooth.com promo code bootleg
that's it
Snoop I think is the most famous rapper
of all time
who do you think yeah who's more famous
than Snoop nobody Drake's not more
famous than Snoop ah Jay-Z's now more
famous than Snoop ah brother snowball
that's a fact yeah Snoop Dogg who was
bigger Peak Snoop I'm talking about at
their very at their Peak
peek Snoop Dogg or Peak 50.
snow you think it's close close for so
it was close though 51 Diamond didn't he
yeah I mean get Richard I try in this
[ __ ] that was a that was a moment
that was like it's close you know I
always say it was those two at their
Peak I'm not talking about overall I
just mean Peak if you were to take like
their top years in terms of just like
who was the hottest who had the most
energy it's those two and then I think
it's like everybody else because I think
Wayne's [ __ ] was like over time he had
to you know what I mean like he had like
a cool like 08 was like his Peak but
yeah but it's like controversy sales it
wasn't 50 though it was the controversy
and then you got to think like Drake was
more like 13 years in we're now in the
Drake's run and it's like he's still the
top guy but like I'm not sure at a
certain point in time like Drake had
more energy than 50 or Snoop like not
right just
um stood at the time oh [ __ ] was just
crazy that's like never been done before
yeah it's crazy so it was crazy one of
one for sure look man the new album is
out the new album's out uh Rodney Brown
Jr
um
the streets calling it a classic I want
you to hear it I want you to listen to
it and tell me how you feel just press
play from beginning to end at least one
time yeah at least at least one time
don't don't look at the your artist on
there and say oh I want to go to this
song no go from number one to number 20
and just tell me how you feel I mean
tell me you know I'm saying how you feel
about it I love it I like it a lot
um the people of it that's hurt us thus
far they love it uh and Rodney Brown Jr
we're gonna have you know we're gonna
tour uh we got the novo show November
4th November 4th man it's it's lit right
now bro I'm back outside I have to wait
three and a half years for another album
um
it depends on the demand for real for
real because don't say that just say no
no three and a half years not because I
don't want you to just I don't want to
be another [ __ ] pandemic but listen I
don't want you to I don't want you to I
don't want you to uh not listen to this
one just thinking of you know I mean I
don't want you to take this one lightly
don't take it lightly don't take it
let's worry about this right now Rodney
Brown Jr is here right now Rodney Brown
is my government so you know the
severity uh and
sincere-ness of this album you know what
I'm saying uh Rodney Brown Jr that's my
government you know I assumed when I saw
I said I hope that's his name because of
someone else's name for sure I'm saying
so you know that was funny but listen
that uh [ __ ] that's right now is the
[ __ ] that you need to listen to you know
what I'm saying and buy some tickets
November yeah and buy a ticket there's
no room for November 4th we're gonna we
lit you know we're gonna have merch
there um
you'll see Snoop Dogg there you never
know Snoop YG mustard
OT is definitely gonna be there OTS
everywhere I think he has stunt doubles
somehow OT Genesis is everywhere at the
same time him and A.D got some Voodoo
[ __ ] going on because before A.D was on
no jumper A.D would be everywhere I'd be
in Scottsdale one night oh ads at the
club I'm DJing at and then the next day
I'd be DJing in LA and he'd be there and
I'm like yo what the [ __ ] going on
with your life bro you have no
responsibilities
I love him that's my brother for real
shout out A.D Shadow OT he'll probably
be there Eddie will probably come out
and do juice just for the culture I mean
why not you never know let's do it boom
RJ appreciate you man love you brother
yes sir